hey guys how's it going I know this is a
late upload and I'm kind of late to my
own 12,000,000 party but that's because
I didn't know that I was gonna be making
a dedicated video like this because
after me and the boys worked very hard
on wolf and we set out to make that
bigger and better and funnier than meow
and we think it's good but I'll leave
the judgment up to you guys you guys can
check out wolf compare the two I don't
care links are in the description but as
far as this video goes I didn't want to
do a dedicated video because part of me
feels like I must sound annoying for how
many times I repeat myself and I just
got out of shower as for my hair still
wet and I was thinking about you know
this whole YouTube thing that I do and
this whole channel that I have and and
this dialogue that I have with you guys
and it's really interesting because on
April 4th of 2012 I believe that's the
day I might be wrong it's so long ago
now I uploaded my first video to YouTube
and when I think about that you know I I
think back on you know the smaller
aspect of the channel that I have had
and I think about the more intimate
moments that I had during that time and
a lot of it's because it was very fresh
and new and it was like a new adventure
to me and it was new and interesting and
everything was new and and every single
milestone that I got you know was a new
adventure and a new amazing thing and no
one had ever done that even though a lot
of people had done that already but for
me it was really new and interesting and
amazing and you know that feeling
has not really diminished all that much
it still amazes me you know 12 million
is like number I don't even know and so
you know I think about these things I'm
sorry I gotta see my teeth I don't know
but I think about these things and I I
look back and I'm like did I feel the
same way oh yeah I did I remember I was
just a dumb goof that was amazed that
anyone watched his videos in the first
place and you know I I was I look back
right before I recorded this video I got
a little teary-eyed because I there's
one video that I can always look back on
and remember and it always gets me and
some of you guys have seen it if you
haven't I'll link it in the description
too it's the markiplier project 20,000
subscriber milestone video and that
video is very very special to me and mo
see mostly because of the part where Bob
speaks I get even I'm just thinking
about it kind of gets me III remember
the part where Bob speaks and I have it
like right here and I'm afraid to play
it because I'm gonna start crying and
it's not gonna be good but what you know
he is exactly the guy that you
think he is I know there are a lot of
people on the internet who you know seem
kind of fake and and I know people have
accused mark before of you know his
reactions are insincere he yells just to
be ridiculous but he's exactly the guy
that it seems like he is I've been
friends with him for years now and it's
just so great to see people finally
appreciate what I've always known was
it's it's the moment where Bob you know
he vouches for me and the fact that he
does that is it's it's it's really
meaningful to me and you know that that
and everything else said everyone said
in the video and and the things that
people have said in videos down the road
the things that people have said in
other videos that are dedicated to me
and the fact that anything is dedicated
to me is all is you know astonishing
it's incredible it's so stupid that I
deserve any of this
I don't I don't deserve any of this and
you know I'm really really really
grateful I really really am grateful I'm
so grateful you guys don't know
you guys don't know like what I've been
through to get here
mmm oh man you guys don't know how
grateful I am
and you guys don't know how grateful I
am that I get to do this and I say it
over and over that's where I'm afraid
that it's coming off as being ridiculous
cuz ice I repeat myself so much I say
the same thing every time I do a
milestone video I say the same damn
thing but I am I'm really grateful
like I really sincerely am I love doing
this and I love the fact I get to make
videos for you guys and I know there's a
lot of like pessimism on YouTube and
there's a lot there's always been stupid
going on on YouTube and trolls here
and there that's always existed but I've
always been so proud of what you guys
have done and the stances that you guys
have taken and and not letting small
things like that bother you because
there's so many bigger problems than the
stupid things that people argue about oh
man and it's just it's good to know that
we here can do something really cool and
this weekend if you didn't know the 26
we're doing a charity livestream I don't
know what charity for I haven't even had
the brainpower to think about it but
just like thank you guys so much for
being here and thank you to my friends
you know who stuck with me and you know
I think like there's people that I've
disappointed on the way coming up here
and there's people that have been like I
think the boys are home but you know
there's people that I've I've forget it
there you know there have been people
that I've disappointed have tried my
best to make everyone happy and I know
I'm not gonna make everyone happy I know
for a fact I'm not gonna make everyone
happy but just thank you guys so much
for being here and thank you for
believing in what I do and thank you for
being a part of this and what I do
because
that's really special the boys are
definitely home so I need to wipe my
tears before they start making fun of me
so anyway thank you guys again so much
for watching and thank you for 12
million subscribers I'm sorry I shed
tears again didn't mean to do it I'm a
freaking mess but this is what you get
this is all you get this is the
markiplier you get it's as dumb and
stupid as it is so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye